à moto vers le tournant totalement
chargée peut plus être pour lui ces deux
dames du québec ont vécu une expérience
semblable à leur arrivée au nouveau
brunswick elles se sont heurtées à des
embûches et n'ont pas pu accompagner
leur père au moment de leur mort en
réponse à certains de ces événements
la ministre de la santé affirme qu'elle
va lancer une enquête
mais des histoires déchirantes il s'en
passe aussi chez les proches des
patients qui risée de nouveau brunswick
à moncton
un patient a dû faire le choix à savoir
lequel de ces enfants pouvait lui rendre
visite avant de mourir alors que les
règles ne permettait que deux visiteurs
au total c'est idiot qui voyagent ils
ôtent toute la culpabilité de celui qui
vole aux autres est chez eux qui ont
essayé de les faire rentrer été ne
serait ce pour quelques heures juste
pour dire bonjour puis si on veut dire
on les habille et oulémas des masques on
vous remet à se protéger
puis ben ça c'est sûr ça pour penser
cela devient frustrant pour le personnel
de la santé qui comprend l'importance
des consignes sanitaires mais qui
souhaitent aussi accompagner les
patients quand c'était juste les deux
personnes non c'était il y avait les
infirmières étaient détenus parce que il
jouait le rôle de garde d'insécurité
selon la médecin aux soins palliatifs
des mesures devraient être déterminé au
cas par cas dans les ports dans du
quotidien on est vraiment dans une
moment particulier de la vie un moment
qui est très très très important un
moment qui est difficile
puis on a des familles qui sont en crise
ce que j'aime moins c'est quand on dit
non c'est un non catégorique il n'y a
pas d'ouverture a discuté depuis le 2
mars les patients aux soins palliatifs
en droit de recevoir la visite d'une
personne désignée à la fois elle doit
être sur une liste de dix personnes
fournit au préalable à l'hôpital ici ça
de l'or se nourrit du canada moncton